Film Courage: What’s the secret to finding
truth when making a documentary?
I mean…is there anything that you say or
do that helps you find it?
Joe Berlinger: We could spend hours and hours
and talk about truth in documentaries because
I…look…I’m a firm believer that all
documentary filmmaking, all media is inherently
subjective.
You shoot hundreds of hours of footage.
Only a couple of hours end up in your final
film.
There are days you are not there to cover
a story.
You have to choose a camera angle.
Every camera angle communicates a different
emotion potentially.
You make thousands of editorial decisions.
So what’s guided me is that I’m not looking
for the capital truth (capital “T” truth
in a situation) because I think the truth
is very elusive and subjective depending on
from what point of view you are looking at.
What I look for in my films in as emotional
truthfulness.
An emotional truthfulness about the human
condition or the subject that you’re looking
at.
You know, in PARADISE LOST it because clear
that these guys were railroaded.
But a different filmmaker possibly would have
made a different film.
So I think filmmakers who think they are presenting
the absolute truth about a particular subject,
I have potentially…certain kinds of films,
straightforward, history you know I think
the more you know hitting the truth whatever
that means is possible.
But what I’m looking for is the emotional
truthfulness of a situation.
The truth rises to the top if you allow both
sides to have their say.
Treat the audience like a jury and not pound
a specific message over people’s heads.
It has always been the method that I’ve
preferred.
Even in this film, even though it’s a film
about denial, there’s a section of the film
in which those who don’t believe that it
took place, they’ve been given a chance
to air their views and we allow the audience
to make up their own minds about it.
So to me that’s what I mean about emotional
truthfulness.
You air all sides of an issue.
Don’t pound a message over the viewers head
and you let the truth rise to the top.
In CRUDE, some people were surprised that
I allowed the executives to be interviewed
and to present their point of view about the
case.
But I think I trust the audience to come to
the right conclusion about the emotional truthfulness
of the situation.
And sometimes the emotional truthfulness of
a situation is not necessarily what you think
the film is about.
You know for example, in CRUDE the indigenous
rainforest dwellers of Ecuador and their American
representatives were making a case and confronting
this major gasoline corporation for creating
this cancer zone the size of Rhode Island
through bad drilling practices.
This company was claiming that this was not
the case and the pollution that is there is
the responsibility of the state oil company.
Some people may think that I was making a
film about the absolute truth of that situation.
For me, the absolute truth of the situation
(the emotional truth of the situation) that
I was trying to talk about is that we are
destroying the rainforest, that the people
who most deserve to be treated well were being
treated horribly.
And that there were a whole other set of reasons
I was making that film, to bring justice to
these people.
So sometimes the subjective truth of a situation
is not always what the filmmaker is necessarily
trying to present, at least that’s how I
look at it.